a pro-independence party in the Spanish
region of Catalonia is calling for mass
civil disobedience it's angry about
Spain's unprecedented decision to
takeover Catalonia's regional government
after a vote for independence hundreds
of thousands people poured into the
streets of Barcelona over the weekend to
protest Seth Doane is in Barcelona with
how people are reacting to the Spanish
government's hardline south good morning
good morning this political crisis has
escalated to the point that Spain
central government is in essence saying
okay we'll take over now as they seek to
impose direct rule here in Catalonia
those favoring independence made it
clear what they thought about direct
rule by Madrid 450,000 people filled
Barcelona streets Saturday in protest
if Spain's Prime Minister Mariano Rajoy
gets his way the semi-autonomous region
of Catalonia will see its president lose
his job and top ministries and
government functions managed by
caretakers from Madrid likely until new
elections are called those steps must be
approved by Spain Senate that's expected
later this week in a television address
Catalan president Carlos Bustamante
called the central government's latest
move the worst attack on Catalonian
institutions and its people
since the Franco dictatorship may be
thought of from Cusco Franco I don't
think selfishness exclusion is good for
business and definitely not good for
people Carlos the doulas a lawyer in
Catalonia sees separatists here as
breaking the law and Spain's effort to
seize power as a necessary step he
likens it to pushing an emergency button
it's like Alabama or any other state
declaring the US Constitution doesn't
apply on their territory
the building behind me here is the
equivalent of the White House here in
Catalonia it is where leaders are
plotting their next move
meanwhile in another push toward
autonomy in northern Italy two of the
richest provinces went to the polls over
the weekend and voted overwhelmingly in
support of finding more autonomy in the
way their tax dollars are spent and
Noora that was one of the big issues
here
what a story Seth Doane in Barcelona
thank you